es un Calvario para los residentes de
harkies volvieron a amanecer bajo los
bombardeos rusos que terminaron dañando
docenas de viviendas
Aquí no hay vehículos militares es el
centro de la gente vive aquí suele ser
muy tranquilo no hay objetos militares
cerca no tengo ni idea de porque a un
bombardeado nuestro patio
en cramatorsk en la región de doñesk se
vivió Algo similar un misil impactó en
el centro de la ciudad situada a 20
kilómetros de la línea del frente más
cercana
escuchamos dos potentes explosiones a
las 4 de la mañana una fue muy potente
la segunda un poco menos vimos en el
centro de la ciudad Así que oímos
bastante bien nos despertamos por la
expulsión y nos trasladamos a un lugar
más seguro el pasillo de nuestro piso
estos ataques se suman al perpetrado en
la región desde mi propetrovsk en zonas
cercanas a la central nuclear de saboría
la mayor de Europa que dejó más de 10
civiles muertos y varios heridos el
presidente celenski condenó este ataque
y acusó a Rusia de terrorismo nuclear
Aunque el enemigo niega a estar
implicado
todos estos son signos del terrorismo
nuclear de Rusia Rusia se ha convertido
en un país terrorista y tiene como
Rehenes a las centrales nucleares
chantajeando a todo el mundo con un
posible desastre
en efecto pidió sanciones a la industria
nuclear rusa y más apoyo económico un
pedido que fue concedido en la medida
que algunos países europeos y aliados de
Ucrania prometieron En una conferencia
en copenhague enviar más de 1.500
millones de euros al país en guerra en
concepto de ayuda militar contra Rusia